[موسيقى]
والله زي ما انتم شايفين والله العظيم
شيكل واحد ما في معانا لما جينا على
الجنوب طلعونا اليهود على الجنوب قالوا
منطقه امنه على الممرات على الطريق الامن
قالوا لنا ال طريق الامن وقفونا بالطريق
واخذوا مارينا كلها اجينا ه ما معناش ولا
شيكل طلعنا من غزه رحنا على المغازي رحنا
على نصرات
رحنا على نصراط ورحنا على خانون وجينا اخر
شي على رفع هان يعني ما ضلش مكان نروح
عليه والله ليلا غرقنا ميه ميه والله
العظيم نايمين على الميه والله لو تحس
واعيه اطلع ميه غير الشتاء اللينا في
الخيمه ميه والاولاد طلوا ميه في اكل اكل
فيش اكل اصلا رغفين خبز كانوا موجودين
كعلم الله كيف دبرنا وراحوا في الميه عشان
نسد جوعنا بس اقل ما فيها نسد جوعنا بدنا
احنا بدنا نعيش بكرا ه احنا ه عايشين
بكرامه غصب عن نتنياهو غصب عن نتنياهو
احنا عايشين هنا بكرامه ولو بدك تموت انا
تان نطلع من هنا لو ايش ما بده يصير احنا
باقيين هنا وصامد
هنا والله غرقنا الليله والله غرقنا مطر
وهي مشد شوادر عننا هي اولادنا اد مش
عارفين نعملهم في حرامات بططين يمهم وبدنا
يعني بدنا نج على بيوتنا اهم شي كلامك
صحينا
خيم يا عالم حص علينا يا عالم حص فينا
كيلو كيلو باميا والعصايا حاميه في الليل
ما بنعرف ننام بالمره منكت القحه اللي بف
عنا في الليل والبرد وهذه بتخبط في هذه
وكل اللي هذه هودت عيننا ب نقطها بالشتا
تبعها والحمد لله الاكل صعب والشرب صعب
الميه صعبه وال حتى القاعده في النهار
صعبه
م